В ортопедичній мастерні Олександра Стеценка кипить робота.
Колись його метою було допомагати постраждалим від Чорнобильської аварії.
Після початку війни на Сході України він став потрібен сотням солдатів та мирних мешканців.
П'ятирічна Меланія народилася у прифронтовому Маріуполі.
До лікаря вона регулярно приходить з бабусею.
Її мама загинула 3 роки тому під час обстрілу Маріуполя російськими "Градами".
Дівчинка сиділа на колінах в мами, але вижила,
хоч і отримала сильні поранення осколками ракети.
З такими трагічними історіями лікар стикається постійно.
Він сподівається, що ці люди зможуть, попри важкі поранення, вести активне життя.
Війна на Донбасі - це реальність, яка постійно з ним.
Це війна. Російсько-українська війна. Це однозначно.
Погано, коли сусід воює з сусідом, коли брат... старший чи молодший...
Це завжди погано. Але найголовніше, що гинуть люди.
Найголовніше, що люди калічаться, стають інвалідами.
Так, як це сталося з Меланією.
Ольга Абдурашитова залишила в Маріуполі все, що мала,
щоб онука могла отримати краще лікування в Києві.
Вже два роки дитина носить протез.
Який росте разом з нею - його потрібно постійно переробляти під дитячу ніжку.
Щоб Меланія могла знову гратися з іншими дітьми,
а її життя хоч у цьому стало нормальним.
Як, власне, і для її бабусі.
Але там стільки було!.. Все горіло. Це було страшно.
Настільки все у вогні, люди бігли, хто куди міг, розумієте.
Все було так несподівано.
Люди рятувати дітей, свої життя рятували, тікали…
Я подзвонила черговий раз на мобільний телефон,
мені відповіли, але трубку взяв чоловік.
Я питаю "А де Оля?" Він каже - в морзі.
У мене була істерика.
У 2014-му мама Меланії підтримувала введення російських військ на Донбас,
але сама загинула під час обстрілу Маріуполя.
Проте це все вже стало історією.
На лікування та протезування дівчинки гроші збирали по всій Україні.
Це спільна біда: війна на Донбасі досі приносить нові жертви.
28-річний Дмитро Краслянський котрий рік лікується після того,
як улітку 2014-го отримав поранення під Савур-Могилою.
Його буквально зшивали докупи, він довго був на межі життя і смерті.
Дмитро переніс загалом 28 операцій.
Тепер черга лікаря Стеценка ставити його на ноги.
Після того всього, що довелось пережити,..
як сказати...
життя стало іншим. І кожну секунду ти починаєш цінувати.
Люди он нарікають "немає машини, нема того, нема цього..."
Є що поїсти, є куди і з ким піти, є сім'я - це вже дуже велика  радість.
Вам страшно було?
Не боїться тільки хвора людина.
Треба!
Якщо треба - ще раз піду.
Понад десять тисяч людей за чотири роки війни загинули на Донбасі.
Війна продовжується, й ніхто не знає,
коли вона закінчиться та скільки ще життів забере.